the Seahawks are currently the six seed
at five and five and they play the team
directly in front of them the Carolina
Panthers meaning they could be in the
five seed by the end of this weekend
which would obviously be huge Doug
Baldwin the wide receiver and two-time
Pro Bowl wide receiver of the Seattle
Seahawks hit that back here on the show
how are you Doug rich thanks Bethany you
bet did I set the stage appropriately
kid for this game you did absolutely so
this is something that is openly
discussed in the locker room this is a
team right in front of us we need to
beat this team because who knows what it
would mean for a tie-break down the line
I mean we're not saying it in those many
words however we know that you know
right now we're kind of playing playoff
football you know that we have to win
the games that we have to learn in order
to get to the Big Dance and so you know
we're approaching them accordingly so I
won't say that we're you know making
this a must-win but we know how vital
these games are down the stretch so
let's talk about this season I mean for
you personally it starts with you being
injured and how are you feeling right
about now week twelve here Doug I'm
getting better it's a process it's a
never-ending process but I am feeling
better
what do you mean by process I love to
walk walk a fan through what you go
through to get ready for a football week
Doug I don't know if I can put it in the
words for people to be empathic to it
you know what to truly understand what
it takes to uh to continuously play at a
healthy level in this game and on both
of my knees I had MCL issues and some
patellar tendon issues in both my knees
have been struggling to maintain to help
out the course of season because I've
been you know one who's been hurt I've
been leading on the other one and then
the other one gets ours and I go back a
little so kind of been in a purgatory
state right now trying to get past this
team and uh you know we're getting it
it's just again it's in a very long
process and then in terms of the team
this season it has been a wild journey
to 500 right now which with six games to
go you've once-upon-a-time been four and
five before and made the playoffs and
now it appears that you're poised to do
that to what how does this season
compared to any others
the past other than what I might have
just pointed out yeah the only thing
that I can really connect it to is the
is the schedule or the the win-loss
record like you stated this is a
completely different team it's
completely different pardon clearly
different players I think in a different
mentality you know we are just different
altogether and so I don't want to
compare that to what we've had in the
past I won't say that this team I do
believe is poised to continue a strong
push and a strong run we have the talent
and we have the mindset it's just it
comes down to us executing consistently
because I think we have the ability to
do that so we'll see what happens so can
you then once how is it different then I
mean is it just different because the
Legion of boom is completely gone and
and that it leaves a void in the locker
room that needs to be filled elsewhere
on the field I mean what that because
that would be the obvious one outside
looking in as to what's different yeah I
would say it's a philosophical one and
maybe even a cultural societal one as
well you know the young guys that are
coming in now they're just completely
different in myself and the guys who
have been here the older guys you know
we were just cut from a different fabric
and that's not to be disrespectful to
the young guys that are here you know
they just grew up in the age of social
media where that's that's what they
that's what they know for a lot of us
younger guys we didn't have that and so
it was definitely a mental transition
that you see in the lock world and not
to say that it's that it's bad or that
it's all bad but there are some there's
some subtle differences you know you the
group that we had when I was when we
were in our prime and those years or the
supervillains and you had guys who were
just I don't even know how to describe
them they were just de limit and and the
mentality was different and the approach
was different and so you know it's it's
a transition again not to say that it's
bad it's just different and so we have
to find our identity amongst that as we
move along so when you're saying they're
more focused on social media as I guess
I didn't oh I was by the way i was about
to correct myself i understand i
understand what i just said and how it
might have twisted what you did say
so then I guess let me openly ask you
when you say they're from the social
media era okay how does that manifest
itself in the locker room or on the
field yeah you have to talk to him
differently you know I think that you
know the the pressure of always being
under the microscope you know whether it
be on the football field or off the
football field and and what they put out
there and what's returned to them
they're always being criticized and
judged and so the mentality is different
and it approach is different in the
sensitivity is different and so yeah you
have to approach it and communicate with
guys differently because they hear
things differently their emotions are
different and again that's okay it's
just it's a different it's a different
world that I've that I've been a part of
and so you just have to have to handle
it accordingly and I think that's a
responsible thing to do what I would say
to you know whether you're older veteran
on a team or parent raising children in
today's day and age you have to be
willing to be empathic to your children
or to the younger generation to
understand and learn how to communicate
with them so that you can get the best
out of it out of them do you think that
this is an NFL thing or just a Seattle
Seahawk thing Doug bowling no I
definitely think it's an NFL thing and I
think that's why Sean Bay has had so
much success is because he's a younger
mind he understands how to communicate
with his with his players especially the
quarterbacks that are coming out
nowadays and so you're gonna see in my
thing you're gonna see younger coaches
having more success because they know
how to communicate with the younger
generation and so I don't think it's
just in a sea dog thing or just a
Minnesota thing I think it's a societal
thing so does it help to have the oldest
child as your quarter as your coach then
is that what you're saying then if you
do if you do have the oldest coach it
helps that he is he acts like a child
you know what I will say yeah that's
that's in some in some ways yes I will
say the great thing about Pete is that
he tries very hard to listen to the guys
and and to learn as much as you can and
you know he takes great pride in that so
that's one thing that I respect
p-ting appreciate about him greatly Doug
Baldwin Seahawks wide receiver here on
the Rich Eisen show have you spoken to
Earl Thomas lately Doug most part about
two weeks ago I spoke to him I'm just to
check on and see how he's doing and he's
doing all right he's a he's Earl how was
the the team affected by that situation
before he got hurt Doug you know I don't
think it played as big of a role as some
people would like to make it out to be I
think that in this business we all
understand the inherent risks and issues
that come with it and next communication
that may be interpreted as selfish or
negative but at the end of the day were
the business and the team is trying to
get the most out of his players and then
move on when they had the opportunity to
do so and the players are trying to get
the most out of their either playing Tom
because it's such a short window and I
think a lot of the guys in the log home
understood that they understood were
always plumbing from and also where the
team was coming from and the importance
of not making it a bigger distraction
that I needed to be and when it all came
back he was a great member of our team
he was supportive he won everything that
he needed to do and he was playing well
and unfortunately you know it ended with
a horrific injury but we still love him
the same and that will never change
do you think he's going to play next
year play football yes sir
he's not Lisa I think he still has that
that you know that that fire in the
still play I have no doubt about that
well for all of us who love football and
love our old Thomas that's great news
Ted Bowen there's no doubt about their
no I know that
no I asked you just because obviously
you'd know you know the guy you spoke to
him two weeks ago I haven't spoken him
in a while so that's why I asked you
there blast we did speak you were about
to talk to the Attorney General of the
state of Washington to talk about what
criminal sentencing reform or if I got
that correct I'm wondering where things
stand with you and what you're doing in
your community your state with with the
powers that be Doug yeah right now I
think
referring to his initiative 9:40 which
we just had on the ballot a midterm
election ballot out here in the state of
Washington then it did pass so we're you
know ecstatic about that but I do think
there's still some some ending of the
relationship between the community and
law enforcement here that needs to be
done in Washington the initiative that
passed was you know definitely
controversial in a number of different
ways but I think that having the
conversations with law enforcement and
showing them why we felt like this was
the proper direction to go in
in explaining that and again being
empathetic to them in the process I
think that's where I'm landing right now
I think that's most important to make
sure that the initiative that we got
passed on the ballot is actually as
effective as we had hoped for it to be
human level so we'll be working on that
in the pursuit future okay and what else
are you working on
that I should know about we should know
about how what what am I not working on
that's the real question
no that there's a lot of things going on
you know I think so me personally I've
kind of found a new niche in life and
trying to just find solutions to
humanistic problems to systemic problems
at that and so you know more songs just
learning as much as I can about the
history of our country and the lives of
humans that are living in our country
now and how they are impacted by
systemic problems and humanistic
problems and trying to find solutions to
those so I'm having great conversations
and you know broadening my horizons in a
number of different ways and it's really
been intriguing and honestly it's it's
been great for my growth not only as a
football player because because I'm
becoming more well-rounded but also as a
human being and and hopefully adds to my
layers as a husband and a father
what do you future father you got one on
the way
not yet well we're working on it okay no
pressure no pressure I just wanted to
ask are you in contact with Kaepernick
at all Doug no I'm not we haven't spoken
in in a few few weeks but I know he's
doing well and
doing a lot of work on his own so what
do you think of when you hear people say
doesn't want to play football that he
wants to play that he does not want to
play football there are some people out
there who think that he does not wish to
play football that if he had his choice
he would be doing what he's doing as
opposed to be doing what he's doing
while also being a football player you
know I'm not I can't speak for him but I
will say that I think he's in a very
unique position in a unique situation
he's doing some things that are very
very strong in our community and in our
society and you know he's obviously
getting a lot a lot of backlash for it
getting a lot of praise for it
and he's in a very dangerous situation
because when we put yourself out there
like that you seek a lot of attention
both the good and the bad and I know
that he would probably love the place
football as we all enjoy playing it as
you know as young men in this game you
know still being able to live out our
childhood dream I'm sure he would love
to play the game but I think that his
calling and what he's doing now is so
much greater than the sport and the
lasting impact that he's gonna be able
to leave and create this you know if you
continue to do so in a positive way
will be far greater than any legacy he
could leave on the football field and
what can I not personally believe that's
you know that's way more important than
anything you could do sure what what
what what do you and your colleagues or
you and your teammates think of when you
see other quarterbacks get signed who
don't have nearly the resume that he has
or have been out almost as long as he
has and they get opportunities as second
and third string quarterbacks in the NFL
so honestly I don't need to pay too much
attention to it I think that for the
most part my opinion is that this is a
business I understand why business
decisions are being made and that's not
to say that these aren't business
decisions being made it's just my
personal opinion in my beliefs and so
I'm not surprised by it and you know
again going back to what I said earlier
I think that what Kaepernick is doing
this way more important than the
business side of the NFL so I support
him on that regard
all right Doug Baldwin I always love our
chats mad at Doug Baldwin jr. on Twitter
what does Thanksgiving look like for you
Thanksgiving looks like my wife is going
to be cooking for my to my best friend
we're gonna have Sierra's over you know
don't have places to go during the
holidays during this time so they're
gonna come over which you can have a
family feast together okay so it's not
everybody getting together the Griffins
house she came and you know and she
killed no no not at all could it they
don't know to cook what do you mean they
don't know to cook so in or not gonna go
to the house yeah you know what I gotta
be honest with you that's kind of silly
two bachelors I mean they probably
they're probably eating they're probably
eating you know out of cans no one
knowing where I used to always a
bachelor probably and they're still
young you know they haven't they haven't
explored what it is to actually have a
Thanksgiving and have people over
Thanksgiving on their own you know them
hosting so we will not be doing that
okay hey Doug I really appreciate
everything as always like I said you're
one of my favorite guys to talk to
because it's more than just about
football and then there's a huge
football game this weekend I mean at
Carolina this is it because the issue is
I'm sure folks might remember and I
don't mean to bring up any bad memories
they had a big win in your house and
their run to a Super Bowl one year and
I'm sure you'd like to do the same right
back at them
absolutely Doug take care of yourself I
will always that's Doug Baldwin of the
Seattle Seahawks here in the Rich Eisen
show the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience